you want to go with something kind of
worn this family a little sporty to
referee again randomly well that hurts a
little we've been friends for probably
about four years now and we've been
friends for two months well I've
actually like gotten a lot of flack for
my wardrobe from this friend my wardrobe
would probably be held together by the
staples of polo shirts jeans and
t-shirts my girlfriend who's from
California thought that I was like
dressing as a caricature of someone from
the Northeast I grew up in the south so
I got some southern he says I wear like
a lot of baseball tees coincidentally
I'm wearing one right now I would say my
style is like one of the hipster he's
super put together all the time I have
considered that people might like to
change and go hey buddy really like the
new wardrobe he did cuz the old stuff is
terrible well there's definitely gonna
be an upgrade and a downgrade I'm gonna
look snazzy as hell and I think I'm
gonna look like a rock star so we're
both in for a treat I don't know this
pink polo thing is uh it's in public
it's happening all right it's day two I
am wearing Corey's Henley and jacket and
my shoes on I feel vaguely like Indiana
Jones this is atrocious like why would
you give this to me I'm about to get to
know him even better than I do because
I'm gonna walk a mile in these argyle
socks
so I went to try to smooth the parking
attendant lady with little hey hi like
you know southern charm she was not
having it I blamed sweater I also got a
compliment about the jacket I was
wearing it was Ryan's green letterman
jacket I'm starting to not really notice
that I'm wearing different clothes the
only thing that I do notice is that I'm
just a lot more comfortable so I just
talked to my cousin and she said that
she doesn't like she can't tell the
difference between these clothes in my
normal day I am rocking a windbreaker
and a Cubs shirt zip it up
let's go to a soccer match and just like
some people are back no I'm saying
alright another day in Corey's clothing
I wore it to work today the reception
was very positive save for one person
who asked if I joined a boyband recently
but I think that's an outlier and I
think this look is a hit
the only thing about Kevin's clothes
that I really don't like is this belt
but this thing every step I take it
keeps loosening and I keep having to
like tighten it like ten times a day so
I feel like kind of a dick because I
made a big deal about how crappy this
sweater is but it's actually really
comfortable these shorts are awesome
they're not pretty to look at we'll make
no bones about that but they are
comfortable they are breezy they are
warm these joggers that I'm wearing
there are probably the most comfortable
pair of pants I've ever worn in my life
I'm gonna be pretty sad to say goodbye
to these clothes at the end of the week
nobody noticed I was dressing
differently my family and my friends and
my cousins all said yeah you look the
same I kind of had like an identity
crisis because I was just like people
were starting to call me Ryan this is
kind of weird I'm not used to wearing
this sort of stuff like everyday working
from a group of clothes that I've never
seen before it really made me sympathize
with my girlfriend because I always like
to tease her a little bit about how long
she takes to select the right outfit now
I can't understand when you really gotta
like take a look at it then my pants are
starting to fall down he's got thicker
calves and thighs than me so maybe
that's why so things gave me these red
shorts the shorts with the shirt you're
really going for a Power Move there I
kind of combo that's confident and
towards the end of the week I was just
like maybe I'll invest in some baseball
tees he's got this sweater with like
sort of a shawl collar on it someone
asked me where I bought that and then I
had to have the uncomfortable
conversation of I don't know I'm wearing
another man's clothes wait wait wait
it's not as weird as you think it's
quite lucky that we have is that we're
the same size I know right it was super
fun and now I can wear his clothes and
you just ask and him give them to
drop of a hat which is super creamy my
girlfriend Becky the windbreaker that I
was so opposed to she thought it looked
hot
good breakers are in people no that's
not the message of this video